[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 sport l'émission
de la rédaction consacré à l'actualité
sportive du département voici lé titre
de ce elle lundi 20 novembre après les
gants de boxe les tatamis et les kimonos
du judo ce week-end le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueillait les championnats de france
retour sur l'événement en début
d'émission sept défaites en huit matches
le retour en fédérale 2 se passe plutôt
mal pour le club de plaisir manque de
confiance mauvaise préparation ou encore
mauvais recrutement nous recevront en
plateau un entraîneur et un joueur pour
tenter de comprendre la crise de
résultats que traverse l'équipe pour le
moment johan guillou sera notre invité
aussi sur ce plateau champion de parra
tennis nous évoquerons avec lui son
changement de club et ses ambitions pour
les prochaines années
le judo étaient donc à l'honneur ce
week-end au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'enceinte
olympique a accueilli pendant deux jours
le championnat de france de seniors 1re
division en tout 800 participants
répartis dans cette catégorie est
différente ont enfilé leurs kimonos
mélanie poké et les arènes reviennent
sur l'événement sportif shido yu chi ou
encore ricky wac et le vocabulaire des
judokas a résonné tout le week-end au
vélodrome national de saint-quentin pour
l'occasion le vélodrome s'est adapté les
tatamis ont pris place pour accueillir
le championnat de france seniors 1re
division qui a réuni près de 800
combattants
le silence est d'or troisième âge c'est
les gens quand
encore gravi les échelons de mines
benjamins minimes cadets juniors seniors
dont 4 on jase 18 ans je pense c'est
quand même une première au niveau
national c'est le top
on ne peut pas inventer plus aujourd'hui
est donc pour nous c'est un honneur
d'une part et puis bah on est ravis
d'accueillir toute la france par le beau
département des yvelines des combats
féminins et masculins dans cette
catégorie de poids différents les
judokas ont ainsi pu rencontrer de
nouveaux adversaires et tester leur
niveau
j'ai fait deux tours et voilà
malheureusement bas ça s'arrête là bon
je suis quand même content de moi j'ai
39 ans donc pouvoir faire encore les
championnats de france bah voila je fais
avec mon mari en plus donc mes filles
viennent nous supporter voilà ce ca que
du bonus un peu mal au début
bah je perds mon premier combat je suis
pas repêché derrière 17 évinois ont
combattu sur les sept tapis installés
pour l'occasion en plein coeur du
vélodrome
une transformation apprécié par les
participants c'est assez rare que sont
complètes comme ça les tapis souris et
c'est assez bien je pense que pau public
ça doit être assez assez agréable aussi
qu'on pouvoir avoir la vue sur tous ces
sans passer par moi ça change
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines au lieu de
rencontres sportives depuis la rentrée
ne va pas s'arrêter en si bon chemin
d'ici la fin de l'année il accueillera
des compétitions de badminton et de
sports de combat
[Musique]
on passe aux résultats en bref des
équipes yvelinoise ce week-end avec en
basket la défaite des filles du chéné en
nationale 2 une cinquième défaite en
huit matches de championnat qui confirme
le début de saison en demi-teinte de
l'équipe les filles du chéné 108e de
leur classement
les garçons eux en revanche continue de
cartonner sixième victoire en six
matches le week-end à domicile et quelle
victoire garder le score 97 39 face au
dernier du classement il est vrai il
reste logiquement premier de régionale 2
et peuvent sérieusement envisager la
montée en football nouvelle victoire
aussi et de versailles en déplacement 1
0 à aubervilliers en nationale 3 dans un
championnat très serré où toutes les
équipes se tiennent en un point
les versailles et sont 3e avec 17 points
en neuf journées à seulement deux points
du premier
enfin en rugby carton plein pour les
trois équipes yvelinoise engagé en
honneur versailles s'est imposé à
l'extérieur 27 à 19
cheuvreux s'est imposé à domicile face à
meulan les deux équipes qui sont dans le
même championnat sont bien positionnées
au classement elles sont respectivement
en troisième et cinquième après six
journées
enfin toujours en division honneur mais
dans la poule une le sky rugby s'est
quelque peu rassuré avec une victoire à
domicile contre le rcp 15 35 29
une deuxième victoire en championnat qui
permet au club saint quentinois de
sortir la tête de l'eau et de se placer
à la 7e place du classement le début de
saison reste malgré tout est très
compliqué pour le promu avec un bilan
négatif et déjà quatre défaites au
compteur
alors faut-il s'inquiéter pour le ska et
rugby écoutez la réponse du président et
entraîneur de l'équipe seniors guillaume
payen il répondait aux questions de
mélanie poquet avant la victoire de ce
dimanche
sur les quatre matches perdus vous
perdez de moins de 10 pour 1 chaque fois
qu'est ce qui explique cela
ouais on en fait on a on a deux matchs
comme je disais qu'ils sont sur des
équipes de même niveau
vraiment le même niveau cno et ça se
joue juste à la fin le match qu'on gagne
on gagne 2,1 points
malheureusement je pense que la
différence par rapport aux équipes c'est
qu'ils ont fait une bêtise que l'on sait
que souvent ça se joue pas sur notre
défense on n'est pas trouvée en place
mais plutôt sur l'attaquant au rang des
ballons l'artaud facilement et
l'adversaire profil de ces ballons et et
c'est ça qui fait qu'on perd de peu à
chaque fois c'est parce qu'on est on n'a
pas autre autant encore ans l'attaquant
qu'on travaille à améliorer ça c'est de
faire du jeu cette nouvelle division la
division honneur elle est compliquée
vous vous y attendiez on s'y attendait
parce qu'on monte de division on s'y
attendait on savait plus compliqué parce
que les équipes se sont pas sont plus
équipés justement physiquement notamment
on va en subit un petit peu et notamment
le fait que physiquement on rentre
quelques kilos mais on a quelques
joueurs blessés dont on n'a en plus pas
de chance c'est à dire qu'on vient
d'être premier la division et on a des
joueurs blessés mais c'est pas grave on
continue à faire le dos rond à bosser et
rubis c'est un sport d'équipé donc c'est
pas parce qu'il manque quelques joueurs
pourraient pas continuer à progresser
est ce qu'un système de jeu en
particulier qui a été dit par rapport à
ce que vous auriez pu voir d'autres
équipes
non non non clairement on se concentre
sur notre rugby sur ce qu'on fait
progresser nous après on a quelques
infos sur les équipes adverses donc on
en profite mais on prépare pas les
matchs en s'adaptant à 100% l'équipe
adverse ont fait en forme de nous
comparer l'équipe adverse et et c'est
plutôt dans cet état d'esprit qu'on
positionnez vous avez des points faibles
encore amélioré peut-être vous avez les
blessures à pallier déjà causé des
blessures que tu vois ça va les joueurs
certains vont revenir d'autres vont se
blesser c'est le jeu dans tous les
sports
après nouveau sur ce sur quoi on
travaille c'est pour essayer d'être plus
plus dangereux en attaque on n'est pas
assez dangereux en attaque en défense on
a fait beaucoup de travail on arrive à
enchaîner bonne séquence des longues
séquences de bonne défense par contre en
attaque on a du mal a encore du mal donc
on travaille beaucoup là-dessus pour
mettre en danger la défense adverse
le début est un peu difficile mais
l'objectif la saison elle est loin
d'être terminée on n'est qu'en novembre
le maintien j'imagine voir monter dans
le haut du panier
ouais après nous en fait pour parler
clair avec les joueurs on se fie pas aux
issues de classement fait fi des
objectifs de deux prestations
et pas seulement une victoire une
défaite mais dire est ce qu'on l'a été à
100% ou pas voilà ça l'objectif à chaque
fois et chaque dimanche c'est même et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pourra juger
de son éventuelle remise en forme dès ce
week end et dimanche avec un derby
yvelinois déjà très important et un
déplacement à maisons laffitte le
deuxième du classement dans cette poule
honneur
on va continuer à parler de rugby dans
cette émission avec deux invités en
plateau sébastien roncalli et maxence
doré bonsoir à tous les deux vous êtes
respectivement entraîneur et joueur du
plaisir plaisir rugby club et comme un
peu le sky rigby finalement vous aussi
vous connaissez un début de saison assez
compliquée le niveau est forcément
supérieure vous jouez vous en fédérale 2
ce dimanche vous avez connu une septième
défaite en huit matches contre marcq en
baroeul une défaite
j'imagine qu'il doit être frustrante
d'autant plus que c'est un concurrent
direct pour le maintien et que vous avez
perdu seulement 2,5 points 12 à 7 c'est
le score final je me tourne vers
l'entraîneur déjà un premier bilan de ce
match qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui fait
que vous perdez seulement 2,5 de cinq
points qu est ce qui a cloché ce qui a
cloché
c'est notamment la deuxième mi temps on
a baissé un peu de rythme ils ont fait
tourner un peu elles ont un effectif
assez important
malgré tout on est très content et très
satisfait du match du contenu de
de la solidarité dans les gars ont fait
preuve et on est plutôt en progression
par rapport à ce qu'on propose sur le
terrain le match on pouvait le gagner
même à la dernière minute on a fait le
choix dont on avait un ballon à jouer on
a fait le choix de pas de jouer on est
satisfait de ce point même si c'est vrai
qu'on n'aurait pu espérer rester au
point des finances et revoilà on a on
part avec le point de bonus
donc voilà ça reste quand même positif
et c'était quand même le troisième gros
déplacements qu'on faisait donc voilà
c'est c'est une bonne chose que maxence
doré vous étiez vous sur le terrain
alors frustration même si même si je
relève des points positifs mais quand on
est sur le terrain même avec le point on
n'accepte jamais de perdre j'imagine
vous deviez être vous aussi encore plus
peut-être frustré que l'entraîneur qui
arrive à prendre un peu de recul
clairement nous le dernier ballon on
voulait jouer ça pourra vous le dire on
a râlé un petit peu mais bon après avec
le recul on se dit que c'est toujours un
point de plus que race et d'hautmont qui
sont derrière puis nous reste à jouer
dôme où justement dans deux semaines à
essayer de prendre des points à ce
moment là mais ouais c'est frustrant
frustrant je le disais une seule une
seule victoire depuis le début de saison
un début de saison très compliqué vous
êtes vous êtes promus ça peut peut-être
expliquer les raisons de ces mauvais
résultats
plus généralement qu'est-ce-qui qu'est
ce qui ne va pas depuis le début de
saison selon vous est ce qu'il ya eu
peut-être relâchement après la montée
une mauvaise préparation est ce que est
ce que c'est un manque de chance
globalement est ce que c'est le niveau
qui est tout simplement trop élevé pour
vous pas forcément non mais sur le sur
le premier bloc on voit qu'on a joué des
grosses équipes avec ça rien à voir avec
nous c'est des équipes quasiment
professionnels on n'est pas invités puis
on les regarde un peu joué après la sur
le deuxième bloc tchèques ont accroché
gennevilliers gens même si le score est
large
ça reflète pas le match ils étaient
contents de repartir avec des points de
chez nous et puis là on est en
progression contre marcq en baroeul donc
on a juste gagné 1 re à zurich est un
peu dans le dur aussi mais vous vous
sentez tout de même vous aussi
entraînant un basculement peut-être même
si ça se voit pas forcément encore dans
le résultat dans le côté positif de la
saison en tout cas vous l'espérez
j'imagine mais vous le sentez savent où
me moi je suis très très confiant par
rapport au comportement et
l'investissement des joueurs
on a fait des bons résultats à
l'extérieur même si effectivement on
appris avec 30 points
on progresse dans le bon sens je suis
très très confiant pour le futur
est-ce que ce début de saison c'est
aussi un nouvel entraîneur vous du coup
peut-être des consignes une une façon de
faire a remarqué à à ce que ça match
avec les joueurs est ce qu'il peut être
un début de saison compliqué à cause de
ça le fait que ce soit un nouveau coach
une nouvelle consigne nouvelle façon de
voir les choses non non je pense pas je
pense que les joueurs sont très bien
adaptés je pense qu'ils sont plutôt
contents
des changements qu'il ya eu sans
dénigrer les gars qui étaient avant
qu'ils ont fait du très bon travail
voilà maintenant nous on a fait les
choses en souplesse on n'est pas arrivé
en révolutionnant clé tout le jeu on
amène les choses gentiment doucement
donc ça évolue dans le bon sens c'est
vraiment sur le terrain on voit des
choses qui sont vraiment appréciable
comment comment vit le groupe de
l'intérieur ces moments difficiles vous
sentez l'équipe a battu ou alors au
contraire complètement révolté notamment
avec le calendrier qui arriva on le sait
dans quinze jours comment vous sentez
groupe alors le but ce n'est pas de
créer de problèmes entre son entraîneur
évidemment comme encore qui commet
comment comment vous sentez-vous le
groupe de l'intérieur nettement bien des
dégâts a battu aux dégâts non non non
pas abattu on est dégoûté à chaque fois
de faire donc c'est que c'est que ça
brasse et que tout va bien quand on est
compétiteur on a envie de gagner tous
les matches mais on sait qu'il ya des
équipes bien plus forte que nous on sait
qu'il y en a d'autres à notre niveau il
y en a d'autres qu'on pourra accrocher
des supposés un peu plus forte qu'on
accrochera la maison donc non non tout
va bien alors je précise que vous êtes
pour l'instant 10e du classement que ce
sont les deux derniers qui descendront
ça risque de se jouer à trois ou quatre
on va peut-être voir le classement
s'afficher que dit le coach dans ces
moments là une défaite 12 à 7
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous avez
dit par exemple dimanche et qu'est ce
que vous allez dire toute la semaine
pour pour motiver l'équipe en vue des
dommages très importants qui arrivent
sans tout dévoiler bien sûr non non ce
que je leur ai dit je les ai félicités
parce que vraiment il ya eu un très gros
match de fait encore une fois comme
comme disait match il ya une grosse
densité en face il ya des moyens qu'on
n'a pas malgré ça ils continuent à se
battre tous les dimanches c'est de mieux
en mieux on une fois tu serais pas ton a
pris un point de bonus qui va être
probablement très important et puis et
puis il ya le comportement quoi
ma fille ni vraiment sur une note
positive ils ont envie ils ont envie
d'être ensemble de bosser là on a en a 2
deux matches à domicile qui arrive on a
l'ambition de gagner les deux qu'est-ce
que sur quel point vous allez insisté
cette semaine là aussi on va pas tout
dévoiler si si les joueurs de saint
denis nous nous regarde mais est-ce que
vous allez travailler un point en
particulier le point qui a cloché
éventuellement ce week end
ouais on va on va on va notamment
continuer à travailler sur le jeu au
contact puis ce qu'on a on a encore
quelques soucis bat toujours pareil par
rapport à la densité en phase où on
égare beaucoup de ballons au contact
donc on a on va mettre effectivement
entre autres se tenait en avant donc je
le disais le prochain match c'est
dimanche à 15 heures à domicile à
plaisir contre saint denis on dit
d'ailleurs à tout le monde d'aller vous
supportez j'imagine que les supporters
ont leur rôle à jouer dimanche et c'est
quoi c'est la victoire sinon rien sinon
ça devient très très compliqué vous les
joueurs et j'imagine que que vous penser
qu'à ça déjà avant chaque début de match
mais là encore plus restés sur nous
c'est on joue pas un match pour perdre
donc on rentre pour gagner après on sait
que c'est une équipe encore il va
falloir tout donner le minimum ce sera
un point de bonus défensif mais nous
dormir ghani khan dans quinze jours il
ya la réception du dernier du classement
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur que vos
joueurs se projettent déjà dans ce match
là qui risque d'être encore plus
important j'ai envie de dire que que
celui qui arrive est ce que c'est pas le
risque de la fameuse expression dont on
se moque souvent jouer match après match
mais là là là c'est d'autant plus le cas
non seulement ça pouvait arriver mais
non ils ont bien conscience que les
matches se jouent les uns après les
autres et
on a besoin vraiment de points non on va
pas galvauder un match par rapport à
l'autre depuis le début même si c'est
vrai que pas un stand a pris lé score un
peu élevé on n'a jamais lâché le match
donc même les grosses équipes on a pris
par moment 40 points on prend un mi
temps on a souvent gagné la deuxième
mi-temps donc voilà c'est ça reste très
positif un mot je parlais des supporters
puisqu'il ya deux matches qui arrivent
les deux dimanches à 15h on peut venir
vous voir jouer au stade robert barran
de plaisir qu'est ce que vous dites aux
supporters qui vous regardent déjà pour
les encourager à venir vous voir leur
importance et même en fédérale 2 il ya
un groupe de supporters c'est important
qu'ils soient là maxence d'auray
complètement m'a déjà nous on les entend
sur le terrain on sent que ça plus
derrière il ya souvent du monde quand
même et c'est cool c'est plutôt bien
parce qu'il ya des groupes de personnes
qui viennent nous voir ça vous rassure
aussi son marasme les gens complètement
qui nous suivent qui nient tous ils
savent qu'on est un peu dans le dur mais
ils sont toujours là et puis d'un cerf a
dû leur faire plaisir quoi sans mauvais
jeu de mots est peu pareil par rapport à
ça en tout cas moi j'ai beaucoup de
commentaires positifs ou les gens sont
quand même plutôt content de ce qui se
passe sur le cas de ce qu'on peut
proposer de l'évolution donc ça prouve
que l'équipe ne lâche pas ouais tout à
fait non il ya il n'y a pas de crise à
plaisir en train d'embrasser désirer
j'ai pas posé la question ce que j'ai
bien senti dans vos réponses que
légitimation maintien on est dans les
clous
vous le saviez plus ou moins en début de
saison que ça allait être très compliqué
donc il y aura 200 savait parfaitement
on allait donc ça se passe très bien et
j'ai vraiment bon espoir que ça continue
à évoluer dans le bon sens merci
messieurs d'être venu en plateau bonne
semaine à vous et puis du coup bon
courage pour ces deux matches décisifs
ont refait un petit peu de publicité
avant les deux week-ends ça sera au
stade robert barran à chaque fois a
plaisir à 15 heures contre deux équipes
de concurrents directs pour la
sauvegarde on va dire la survie dans
cette fédérale 2 merci à vous de la
douceur un petit peu à présent avec le
club de grs elancourt maurepas qui a
accueilli ce week-end une compétition 1
départementale interdépartemental au
palais des sports d'elancourt 300
gymnastes des hauts-de-seine de paris du
val de marne et des yvelines ont
participé à l'événement objectif se
qualifier pour les championnats de
france les précisions avec l'une des
responsables du club au micro de camille
lambert
c'est la deuxième étape sur quatre donc
comme ya de la sélection à chaque fois
c'est des étapes à passer pour aller aux
championnats de france qu'elles
aboutissement
de chaque saison que ce soit en
individuel ou en équipe en fait c'est un
sport qui allie
fin de compte faut savoir danser la
grâce il faut savoir aussi manipuler les
enjeux en même temps les engins le
cerceau
mais si le ruban et la corde et le but
c'est de présenter donc il ya des gars
en individuel et à les exercer en équipe
et
après flo les niveaux
monde plus ou moins elles ont un
programme technique à respecter et puis
après faut dans ces faux faux faux pas
on poursuit cette émission avec un
nouvel invité qui est en train de finir
de s'installer en plateau johan guillou
bonsoir vous êtes champion de parra
tennis on vous connaît déjà un petit peu
sur tv 78 on a eu la chance de suivre
votre parcours les années précédentes et
vous êtes avec nous aujourd'hui pour
parler de votre actualité et ce
changement de club depuis septembre vous
jouez désormais pour le tennis club
voisin après plusieurs années passées à
rambouillet dites-nous déjà pourquoi
avoir décidé de te faire ce transfert si
je peux me permettre l'expression si on
peut parler de transfert dans ce cas là
oui on peut parler de transfert donc
c'est surtout que du coup j'ai déménagé
mois sur elle encourt donc dans les
yvelines avant j'habitais sur epernon
dans le 28 ça a été une question surtout
géographiquement de pouvoir me
rapprocher sur un nouveau club et sur un
deuxième point c'est déjà quelques
années que je m'entraînais au
tennis-club de la carrière et puis
j'avais fait un petit peu le tour avec
ce club
et puis avec quelques départs ces
derniers temps notamment le départ de
mon nom de mon coach donc du coup qui
est partie elle même sur
voisins-le-bretonneux et c'est tout
naturellement que j'ai suivi du coup
pour relancer ma carrière dans ce
nouveau club vous avez suivi et puis en
quelques sortes vous avez créé une
section handi en 10 sport pour le tennis
ça n'existait pas avant tout à fait donc
sur le club de voisins-le-bretonneux on
en a profité pour recréer une section de
paras tennis où il ya trois joueurs
jiren de niveau loisir avec mon
intégration sur un plan de sur du haut
niveau donc on a à peu près 4
dans cette section donc maintenant à
jouer au club de boisons pour finir sur
ce transfert vos amis de rambouillet
vous êtes toujours en bon contact avec
eux ils ne nous en veulent pas oui ou
non il ya aucun souci je suis parti en
bons termes en bons termes il n'y a pas
de pas de souci là-dessus alors je le
disais en introduction je parlais de
deux champions ce n'est pas une erreur
puisque vous êtes numéro huit français
si je ne dis pas de bêtises ce qui veut
dire que pour un numéro huit français
vous vous entraînez tous les jours
explique et nous un peu comment ça se
passe concrètement pour vous un voisin
combien d'entraînements combien d'heures
par semaine
alors je tiens quand même à préciser que
mon objectif était la qualification pour
les jeux de rio 2016
donc j'ai hâte un mois la place du
numéro 5 qui est malheureusement n'était
pas suffisante pour participer à ces
jeux il fallait être dur aux quatre
numéros quartier de douala les quatre
meilleurs joueurs français qui sont
sélectionnés moi j'ai décidé de faire
une pause pendant plus d'un an un peu
plus d'un an
donc forcément j'ai perdu quelques
places aujourd'hui je suis numéro huit
français sont classement qui est quand
même vous respectable très respectable
fait partie toujours des meilleurs
joueurs français donc on appelle la
première série et donc moi aujourd'hui
du coup pour m'entraîner donc c'est
quand je recommence du coup avec deux
fois une heure et demie de tennis donc
je suis à trois heures de tennis et une
très petite préparation physique
en parallèle ce qu'il faut noter c'est
que je fais partie - des sportifs qui
ont un métier à côté puisque j'ai un job
à temps plein à côté donc c'est pas lui
dans aussi de savoir ce qu'ils sont
vous faites pour vous organiser du coup
temps plein c'est au moins 35 heures de
cours par semaine au moins j'ai envie de
dire derrière le griot celis avec votre
investissement votre niveau qui induit
forcément des heures de l'entraînement
les compétitions malheureusement
aujourd'hui je dois faire passer en
priorité je dirais là mon travail
puisque j'ai à peu près des semaines à
40 heures par contre sur mes temps de
disponibilité
je m'entraîne le soir donc moi mais
créneaux d'entraînement c'est le
mercredi soir et le samedi matin
donc voilà j'essaie d'optimiser mon
temps libre comme je peux pour pouvoir
assouvir ma passion et essayer de rester
haut niveau avec les quelques
entraînements que à lequel le le
planning d'entraînement que j'ai
actuellement deux entraînements par
semaine mais il ya aussi les
compétitions on a pu en appui suivre
votre reprise qui se passe plutôt bien
vous est notamment champion d'île de
france vous êtes vous avez battu
récemment aussi en simple numéro sept
français vous avez des performances
plutôt honorable pour quelqu'un qui a
fait une pause
bah ça m'a fait du bien de voir que mon
niveau était toujours là donc
effectivement je confirme j'ai gagné les
championnats de france cet été
donc c'était vraiment un reprises j'ai
repris quelques tournois c'est faux en
france où j'ai notamment battu le
dernier dernièrement le numéro 7
français c'est l'équivalent d'un boutre
top 30 mondial donc pour l'instant
j'espère revenir sur ce niveau là d'ici
quelques mois avec espérons le pouvoir
dégager du temps supplémentaire d'ici
fin 2018 2010 1000 2000 2002 bis début
2019 13ème mois c'est la reprise si pour
moi sur les plateaux pour pouvoir
justement m'impliquer dans ce projet
qui est du coup une qualification pour
les jeux paralympiques de tokyo 2020
dans sa serre en 2020 en 2018 la
première étape puisque il faut y aller
je dirais crescendo c'est les
championnats de france c'est ça cet été
vous allez y participer c'est sûr
essayer de faire une performance
saleh en base bien de bien évidemment
c'est l'objectif et après aujourd'hui
avec les quelques tournois que j'ai pu
faire je suis actuellement numéro six au
classement donc j'ai aujourd'hui ma
place pour les championnats de france
donc de tennis fauteuil on doit attendre
malheureusement l'année 2018 puisque la
parra tennis a été intégré à la
fédération française de tennis est donc
maintenant en fait on va aller les
championnats de france de tennis de pas
rater ni du cou ou vont être menées au
même titre que les championnats de
france de tennis valide donc ce sera à
peu près sûr fin juin début juillet 2018
mais aujourd'hui effectivement c'est le
premier objectif que je me donne c'est
une qualification pour ces championnats
de france
et puis ensuite 2020-2025 you vous êtes
je vais dire à nouveau très très motivés
comme pour 2016 le spleen de l'après
2016 est complètement passé aujourd'hui
ouais pas totalement mais après j'espère
en tout cas je mise beaucoup sur un dire
je dirais du coup le l'apport
l'intégration du para tennis au niveau
de la fft je pense qu'il va y avoir des
moyens qui vont se débloquer également
dû il faut développer la pratique du
tennis fauteuil
j'espère que ça va se faire pour
justement aider les clubs financièrement
mais également techniquement en
embauchant des gens qualifiés pour
accompagner
des sportifs comment avec des projets de
haut niveau la motivation est toujours
là après il va falloir aussi moi de mon
côté reconstruire un staff je dirais
complet c'est-à-dire trouver des
sponsors des partenaires espérait le
soutien du comité des yvelines de tennis
pourquoi il se verrait pas espérer alors
je l'avais il faut avoir le soutien à
espérer c'est surtout que j'espère
qu'ils vont adhérer à mon projet donc
c'est en bonne voie il n'y a pas de pas
de souci là-dessus mais je pense que
c'est bien de pouvoir avoir le soutien
de la ligue 2 sont de son département
qu'elle allait que des yvelines donc ça
fait partie d'un des premiers stands
partenaires je dirais voilà qui on va y
aller tranquillement mais sûrement
alors tranquillement parce que c'est en
2020 dans trois ans une dernière
question on se projette dans ces temps
de 1024 paris est ce que vous serez est
clairement trop âgés ou alors vous vous
dites dans un coin de votre tête que
pourquoi pas vous pourriez faire les
jeux olympiques et paralympiques du coup
pour la france en 2024
est ce que vous y pensez un petit peu ou
alors bien sûr que j'y pense et je pense
qu'on en a entendu parler ces derniers
ces derniers temps avec j'irai les
médias puisque on a beaucoup parlé de la
candidature par une 2024 c'est quand
même un événement assez important est
majeur pour la pour la france donc
forcément tous les sportifs français
rêve de pouvoir jouer avec le maillot
tricolore
donc d'ici paris du 24 et un corps du
chemin mais moi j'y crois et après c'est
pas forcément une question d'âge
puisqu'on handisport on peut jouer
jusqu'à 40 ans et voir plus et j'aurais
pas encore 40 ans donc je devrais je
pense
je serai encore un âge où je pourrai
physiquement tenir tête aux plus jeunes
donc on verra bien d'ici là merci i want
you d'être venu en plateau et bonne
saison avoue du coup et qui se voit jeu
pour votre préparation pour les
championnats de france et puis pour
tokyo 2000 vendront à l'occasion de se
revoir d'ici là on referme ce 7,8 sport
avec un rendez vous à noter dans les
agendas c'est mercredi un cross
départemental organisé par l'union
nationale du sport scolaire des yvelines
se lire sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'à 2500 élèves
sont attendus à partir de 13 heures
c'est mercredi
c'est la fin de ce set 8 sport merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi
retour de l'information direct demain à
18h sur l'antenne de tva soit 118 bonne
semaine à tous
[Musique]